tras despegar de una base en oakland
este avión de la fuerza aérea de nueva
zelanda ayudará a determinar con
exactitud las magnitud de los daños en
tonga la erupción del sábado de un
volcán submarino desencadenó un tsunami
golpeando las islas del pacífico con
olas y cubriendo las de ceniza la
catástrofe ha interrumpido las
comunicaciones incluidas las líneas
telefónicas y el internet haciendo la
información escasa este lunes australia
también envió un vuelo de vigilancia
dice esa versión
este es un momento muy desafiante las
comunicaciones están muy muy afectadas
por los acontecimientos de la erupción
volcánica se ha sentido en otras partes
de la región
en nueva zelanda los que tienen
parientes en tonga están cada vez más
preocupados aún sin noticias de sus
seres queridos esta mujer estaba viendo
un evento familiar en directo por
internet cuando la transmisión se cortó
criminalizada es muy muy triste es muy
triste no saber si están viendo este ave
ok la cruz roja dice que hasta 80 mil
personas podrían verse afectadas por la
erupción o el tsunami australia y nueva
zelanda han prometido ayuda humanitaria
wind off shore y
sabemos con certeza que habrá necesidad
de agua limpia debido a las erupciones
de ceniza y quien realmente me imagino
que está causando muchos problemas a los
suministros de agua en tonga ya que la
mayoría de la gente recoge el agua
lluvia
grain la erupción se escucha a unos
10.000 kilómetros de distancia en alaska
y se desencadenaron tsunamis en todo el
pacífico en perú al menos dos bañistas
se ahogaron en las grandes olas y
decenas de personas tuvieron que ser
rescatadas del agua